Transcription: Diana Simões
Relecteur: eric vautier
« Tu n’y arriveras pas. »
« Tu ne seras pas à la hauteur. »
« Tu es nulle. »
C’est violent ce que je dis ?
Vous venez de découvrir
mon monde intérieur.
Ces mots, qui vous paraissent durs,
ont longtemps fait partie
de mon langage intérieur.
Je ne me suis pas présentée,
mais, en ces quelques phrases,
vous en savez déjà beaucoup sur moi.
Je m’appelle Allyah, j’ai quatorze ans.
Je suis passionnée d’arts,
de programmation et de maths.
Mes passions m’ont permis d’aller
au-delà de ce que je pensais
être capable de faire.
Comme vous l’aurez compris,
je ne suis pas très à l’aise
avec la prise de parole en public.
J'ai toujours été réservée.
En maternelle, je voyais
les autres beaucoup parler,
mais moi,
je n’en ressentais pas le besoin.
À l’école et à la maison,
je passais mon temps à dessiner.
J'adorais observer les choses et les gens.
J’avais même un retard de langage à
cause d’un problème que j’ai à l’oreille.
Je n’ai d’ailleurs commencé
à parler qu’en CP.
Pour certains, le silence est une prison.
Pour moi, cela a toujours été mon royaume.
À sept ans, j’ai fait le plus
beau voyage de ma vie.
Je suis allée visiter un artiste
ami de mon père à Dubaï.
J’ai découvert le monde
de la calligraphie et de l’art.
Avec sa fille, je me suis retrouvée
avec un pinceau et de la peinture
à faire des effets de gouttelettes
sur une vraie toile, dans un vrai studio.
Ce jour-là était magique.
Durant ce voyage, j’avais décidé
que je voulais devenir artiste plus tard.
À mon retour en France,
j’avais des étoiles plein les yeux,
j’étais sur un nuage,
mais je vais vite en redescendre.
Dès le début de ma CE2,
je vais malheureusement
connaître le harcèlement à l’école.
À cause de ce que je vis,
chaque jour, je suis très triste
et je maigris beaucoup.
Mes problèmes d’oreille continuent
et je n’entends pratiquement plus.
Je me renferme énormément.
Me rappeler ces moments
et en parler est encore très dur.
Souvent, les victimes de harcèlement
racontent en détail ce qu’elles ont vécu.
Mais raconter, c'est revivre à chaque
fois ce qui nous a fait souffrir.
L’art m’a permis de
surmonter cette épreuve.
Je préfère parler de cela.
Je me suis totalement réfugiée dans mon
monde intérieur pour surmonter ma douleur.
Ces rendez-vous chaque jour
avec moi-même étaient un rituel.
Plus on me harcelait, plus
je passais mon temps à dessiner.
Mes parents m’ont aussi beaucoup
aidée durant cette épreuve.
Chaque jour, ma mère venait me chercher,
me donner des conseils
et des phrases positives.
Ils m’avaient aussi inscrite à énormément
d’ateliers artistiques et scientifiques.
Mon frère, qui a un an de plus, avait été
obligé de m’accompagner à chaque atelier,
car sinon je n’osais pas y aller seule.
On faisait tout ensemble.
C’était comme mon doudou.
Chaque atelier me permettait de découvrir
une nouvelle facette de moi
et de ma créativité.
Chaque jour, j’exprime
mes émotions dans mes dessins.
Cela me donnait la force d’accepter
ce que j’avais vécu la journée
et ce que j’allais vivre le lendemain.
Grâce à l’art et à cette bulle d’amour
de mes parents et de mon frère,
j’ai réussi à sortir du harcèlement.
Cela n’a duré qu’un an,
mais un an de violence, c’est long.
Je ne me rendais pas compte de tout
ce que cette passion m’apportais
et que cela allait me réparer.
À neuf ans, on n’a pas cette réflexion,
on n’est que dans l’action.
Mais j’arrivais quand même
à me rendre compte de la puissance
de me connecter avec moi-même.
Je ressens encore cette énergie
quand je vous en parle.
Elle est toujours là.
C'est cette énergie qui me donne
la force d'être là ce soir.
Au début du collège,
le harcèlement s’était arrêté,
mais dans ma tête, il continuait.
En sixième, mon frère avait un projet.
Il m’avait demandé de l’aider
à concevoir un prototype
qui allait aider les personnes en
fauteuil roulant à faire du street art.
Je doutais encore énormément,
mais je ne pouvais pas lui dire non,
surtout que lui avait
toujours été là pour m’aider.
En plus, son idée d’aider des personnes
handicapées à faire de l’art
était géniale.
J'étais la preuve que l'art pouvait
aider les gens à se sentir mieux.
Je devais le faire
et j’en avais très envie.
Je ne savais pas si j’allais être à la
hauteur, mais je savais qu’avec lui,
cela serait une aventure incroyable.
C’est à la station F, qui est le plus
gros incubateur de start-ups au monde,
qu’on va concevoir le prototype.
On imagine cet objet avec
une vraie équipe d’ingénieurs.
J’étais en charge des dessins
et des plans qui ont été modélisés.
Mes dessins prenaient vie
sous mes yeux en 3D.
C'était incroyable.
Ce que je découvre là-bas
est extraordinaire.
Ma créativité pouvait s’exprimer
grâce à mes deux passions :
la programmation et l’art.
Il n'y avait plus de frontière
entre mes deux mondes.
Pendant quatre mois, on finit hyper
tard, mais j’ai énormément de plaisir
à travailler dur sur ce projet à l’école.
Quand le projet se termine,
je suis tellement heureuse d’avoir fait
un projet utile et qui a du sens.
Le prototype remportera même un prix
au concours Lépine des jeunes inventeurs.
L’été suivant, la station F organise
un summer camp pour les adolescents.
Cette petite voix en moi qui me disait
que je n’étais pas à la hauteur
était toujours là.
J’étais encore très renfermée,
mais la station F me manquait énormément.
J’avais envie d’y retourner pour continuer
à découvrir ce monde du numérique.
Pour être prise, il fallait leur proposer
un projet digital utile aux autres.
Un, deux.
Deux secondes m’ont suffi
pour penser à Kidshare.
Ça sera un site internet pour
redonner confiance aux victimes.
Pour la première fois, je ne doute pas.
Je suis sûre de moi.
Je n’ai rien oublié
du harcèlement que j’ai vécu
et je veux transformer
mon expérience négative
en quelque chose
de positif pour les autres.
La station F retient le projet.
C’est ainsi que Kidshare est né.
Pendant une semaine, je le présente à des
professionnels du monde du numérique.
Je rencontre des gens passionnants.
Je ne m’attends pas à cela,
mais tout le monde adore le projet.
Petit à petit, sans m’en rendre compte,
ce que j’arrive à réaliser me fait
gagner confiance en moi.
Chaque jour, j’adore tellement ce que
je fais que j’arrive à me dépasser
et à sortir de ma zone de confort.
Je m’investis tellement sans réfléchir
que j’arrive à pitcher
mon projet devant un public.
Je remporte même
le prix du meilleur pitch.
C’est un comble pour la fille
la plus silencieuse, non ?
(Applaudissements)
Quand le summer camp se termine,
je décide de continuer
à travailler sur ce projet.
Aujourd’hui, Kidshare, c’est deux choses :
un site internet qui offre
une bulle d’amour aux victimes
grâce à des témoignages de personnalités
qui ont vécu le harcèlement
pour montrer à chaque victime
qu’on est des personnes extraordinaires.
Mais c’est aussi des scénarios
pour l’Éducation nationale,
qui permettent à chaque élève
de développer leur empathie virtuelle,
en les mettant dans la peau d’une victime
grâce à la réalité virtuelle.
En mars 2022, je remporte
le prix Margaret Junior,
organisé par la Journée
de la femme digitale.
Ce prix me fait rencontrer
des femmes incroyablement inspirantes
du monde de la tech.
Je fais des interviews et des visites
de grandes entreprises françaises.
Ils m’accompagnent
aujourd’hui à développer
un site internet professionnel qui
pourrait aider un maximum de victimes
et à développer ma solution
en réalité virtuelle,
qui pourra sensibiliser
un maximum d’élèves.
C’est la plus belle aventure de ma vie.
(Applaudissements)
Quand je repense à mon histoire,
je réalise que, petit à petit,
tout ce qui m’arrive aujourd’hui,
c’est grâce à mes passions.
L’art et la programmation ont été
le chemin de ma construction.
Je ne réalise toujours pas
ce que j’ai réussi à faire
grâce à mes deux passions.
L’art m’a permis de surmonter
la violence du harcèlement scolaire
et la programmation m’a permis
de reconstruire petit à petit
l’estime de moi.
Pour moi, vivre avec passion,
cela a été vital et cela a été ma force.
Avant de repartir dans mon silence,
j’aimerais partager avec vous
une dernière chose.
Il faut que chacun de nous
s’autorise à être passionné,
que chacun de nous trouve
ce qui l’anime dans la vie.
Tout le monde souhaite
avoir beaucoup d’amis,
une vie sociale riche et hyper
connectée avec le monde.
Mais une passion peut permettre
à chacun de nous de recréer un lien
avec une personne
extraordinaire et indispensable,
que malheureusement
on néglige trop souvent.
Cette personne,
c’est vous.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.